reasons why college is a scam part one
college tuition is a scam because
colleges already get more than enough
money without you
one colleges get over 12 billion dollars
from foreign nations each year
two colleges get even more funding from
states three colleges dump all that
money into what's called endowments
which is a fancy ward for a hedge fund
the average student has 32 thousand
dollars in debt while harvard has over
40 billion dollars in his hedge fund
that's enough to pay for all
students tuition for the next 120 years
are they using this money to make
colleges more affordable no
despite having all the extra money
tuition rates are still going up for
some reason college tuition started
mysteriously skyrocketing in the 60s
when student loans became a thing
isn't it a coincidence that college
prices suddenly went up at the same time
the government started letting 18 year
olds sign themselves into massive debt
it's almost like colleges are a big scam
or something so don't be surprised when
places like rutgers university report
that student tuition made up only 30
of the revenue there are plenty of other
ways they make money after making 1.2
billion of their students
another 900 million from the state they
turn around and make even more money
from their hedge fund
colleges don't need your tuition money
because they're already investing state
money and donations into their hedge
funds that are mostly tax free and yet
they're still more than happy to shackle
you and